these people work nine to five have
families and have their own agendas
something this is this place is is a
hive of case officers that have very
sophisticated weapon of manipulating
people that's their job
and sometimes instead of just directing
this weapon against bad extremist
Muslims they are directing it against
their commanders inside the
organizations the organization and that
Mossad suffered strong defeats in in the
in the in the past 20 years and she
invent Israeli domestic intelligence
service is far superior and is having
greatest success with fighting
organizations in the territory like
Hamas and Islamic Jihad then Mossad
success visa vie organizations that are
outside the borders of Israel like like
Hezbollah meaning Shin Bet was
successful in understanding how to
penetrate and how to recruit people even
though these people are working just
with the aim of having the 72 virgins in
heaven which makes it very very
difficult to recruit Mossad doesn't yet
have this sort of capability
you